welcome back to new rockstars and
she-hulk episode one started off with a
sick car crash of oak size consequences
but what if this little visit from the
grand master's career ship was only a
small sign of some poor ragnarok
gladiator goodness to come this is rogue
theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles
that we love my name is mt and going
wrong with me today is yet another woman
who could stop a wall of chainsaws it's
the savage but sweet whitney van
landingham what's going on
up your wall of chainsaws come at me
come at me do you want a texas massacre
i'll show you one
isn't that why phil spector went to jail
the wall of chainsaws that probably is
why like it's that's a weird uh that's a
weird kink that hulk has but uh we won't
question it
yeah we don't we don't we don't question
people's kinks uh on rogue theory we
just ride them some people need a little
bit more to get going
um and
the only man who has gone through the
devil's anus and escapes the car without
the aid of a spaceship it's off-screen
producer brandon what's going on brandon
that's right i went through the devil's
anus and i'll do it again
you hear me i'll do it again nothing
lots of pretty lights i i really like
beautiful it's gorgeous
it's a beautiful anus
right i get that all the time myself
just kidding oh my god i don't know if i
should keep that in mind
um
and finally we cannot forget to mention
the three-time contest of champions
winner tommy bechtold is on the show
with us what's going on tommy hello big
head gang how are you
peaches and cream yeah every all my
gangs here today dude i was there in the
stands watching you succeed in all of
those contests of champions i couldn't
do it without using my goodness couldn't
do it without you
[Laughter]
it was my cheers that were giving you
the strength to fight the whole it's
true one of the best parts about being
friends with tommy is that he always
just like teleports all of his
co-workers to go watch him battle and
it's like you know it's like instead of
doing like office happy hours it's kind
of what we do here we just go watch
tommy fight in an arena it's great
exactly i love it
tommy fight club
he always wins it's just a little
something i do to treat myself
i surround myself
we always appreciate it all right now it
is time for our first topic of today
which i sort of teased out at the
beginning because i have a feeling and
like i don't know this is true rogue but
i have a feeling that she-hulk is going
to end up on sakaar at the very end of
this series because like that ship
showing up and being vital to she-hulk's
origins for the mcu i don't think is a
small deal i think that this is like
marvel studios is like way of being like
all right she-hulk she's going to be an
avenger but we're going to give her
something that like forces her to be
like very avengery like we're going to
give her like a super avengers level
adventure by throwing her into space and
having her being collected by the
collector who
at this point has no idea where his hulk
fighter even went because in in thor
ragnarok bruce boehner i mean the hulk
changes back to bruce banner and
the grand master never saw that he just
thinks that the grand the hulk just
disappeared so i think that he wants to
collect the hulk and now that he saw
sees that there's two hulks on the
planet he's like i'll take both of you
and both of you are going to fight for
me
because why not stop don't shop you know
what i mean he's just gonna take him
plucking exactly you gotta adopt your
hulks don't you know make sure you
rescue you
yeah rescue the hulk and take it out
of the day
you ever been to a hulk mill
it's really sad
they're pretty they're terrible so
inhumane isn't the whole mill just bruce
banner's office at this point that's
just i mean
pretty much uh so mt your your theory is
that the grand master sends this ship to
collect
both hulk and she-hulk when he finds out
there's two hulk so you're also saying
that the grand master was able to
uh reclaim his power from the angry mob
that we last saw him with he was able to
charm his way to the top i don't and i
don't know the grand master's powers i
know he's a very old
being in the universe he's up there with
like the collector but i don't know like
his
physical powers
within the mcu if he has like powers or
if he's just so machiavellian and so
charming that he's able to always weasel
his way up to the top
i think there's something up with the
grand master personally because like he
is an elder of the universe so like
there is that possibility that he just
is immortal and like just cannot die and
so um you know if if someone that can't
die is on a planet eventually he's going
to
reclaim i like i like that idea
they did catch him and they're like
let's kill this guy he's been ruining it
and they they executed him like 50 times
and nothing sticks and they're just like
well he's like you know what
you can you can stay in charge i guess
fine right like i honestly do feel like
we're going to see this like amazing
shot of jen walters in the middle of the
contest of champions like with bruce
about to fight like two like really
strong fighters at the very like the
last shot of the series it's like jen is
like onto car now and like what's gonna
happen we don't know get ready for thor
ragnarok 2.
i love the idea it's a hulk movie called
thor ragnarok 2. which is thor ragnarok
it's the third hulk movie
third thor movie is now the
the second full hulk movie yes
exactly i mean i like the idea of jen
going there but i think i think you're
like
i think they they want to take hulk off
the planet and leave jen on the planet
on earth as like getting the hulks off
the table because i think it feels like
they're moving all of our old powerful
beings off the chess board right now all
of our old powerful heroes
scarlet witch is she's red dust whether
that means she's dead or alive i don't
know uh
doctor strange he's he's chasing that
strange uh in another dimension
a woman showed up out of nowhere and
it's like hey i know your name you gotta
come through this portal with me and
he's like yes please he's like yes
no questions got rejected
yeah yeah he is so ready to chase that
puss he can't even wait to jump through
this mysterious portal
yeah you know
yeah thor's
thor's off doing his own thing now he's
got a kid he's got responsibilities uh
and so this would take hulk off the
planet as well setting up you know young
avengers i don't think they'll ever call
them young avengers because at this rate
they're all going to be in their 30s by
the time they make that movie pretty
much
a regular event but this will be our new
avengers and then for whatever secret
wars becomes
uh
kang dynasty i think that's when our old
heroes will come back uh because they're
so overpowering because the longer
you're in the longer you're in the
marvel cinematic universe like the more
powerful you get right you just kind of
age it's kind of like wrestling where if
you're a wrestler even though in real
life the older you get the less your
body is able to do things the older a
wrestler gets the more powerful they
become like sure hulk hogan can step in
a ring and touch somebody and they go
flying backwards like it's it's very
bizarre so like like the mcu if you just
hang around long enough you just get
more and more powerful so they got to
get these people out on wrestlemania
rules
it's true i mean
it kind of does
fictional wrestling i mean wrestling is
fictional what'd you say empty what'd
you say
about that i'm about to hop on a plane
to boston show you what's real
we're shipping out to boston give me the
stone cold stun up yeah no i i like what
you i brought up brandon about like the
fact that the mcu might want to be like
wanting to remove all the old powerful
heroes or like at least all the powerful
heroes um from the board to allow for
this these new avengers to sort of have
like
i have to work for it whenever they have
to um in the future because like if you
have a hulk on the board the hulk solves
too many problems which is why kevin
feige took him off the planet for civil
war it's like yo if the hulk is choosing
the side
what are we going to do here because
whatever side the whole chooses he's
going to win
expecting hands handouts
hey maybe don't go to starbucks every
day okay
and then you can afford it
to be there at civil war he would have
clearly been on tony's side because a
tony was right and b him and tony are
best friends we know that uh i don't
know about
but the whole game but i like the hulk
being in civil war and when everyone
else is just like oh we're shooting
little missiles near each other and
we're punching each other softly hulk is
just ripping people apart and they're
like no no no no no no no
killing them
these are still our friends they're
still our friends this was just like a
play fight this is a play fight we're
still friends like we still love them
he's like watch like when rhodey got
hurt everyone stopped and was like oh no
roadie's hurt it's like guys what the
[ __ ] do you think you were doing here
yeah
what did you think was going to happen
so i want i want the hulk i want that
what if where hulk's still on the planet
for civil war and he just decimates
steve and his crew they're all dead yeah
and the world moves on peacefully oh
just rips him
yeah he jumps like johnny
yeah like an eighth size
um but yeah no i would really dig that a
lot i would i need to see uh what if
episode were like what if thor and hulk
were involved in civil war yeah like
they would absolutely
destroy the planet oh yeah honestly it
would not be pretty at all um
but yeah i just feel like you know these
hulk characters though like we love them
we love to see them in the mcu they do
present a big problem in terms of like
storytelling because like there's not a
lot of stories that you can really tell
with hulk's sort of being around because
like you know like let's say like you
know a big strong villain shows up in
like an iron heart he's like yo where's
the hulk why isn't the hulk helping why
is like iron heart doing this by herself
so it's like it makes sense for the mcu
to sort of just be like all right no
more hulks on the planet for just a
little while because they're going on
their own adventure but they'll be back
the hawks will return i get that yeah
i mean the hulks will return in a future
installment i feel like there are fans
that complain that like oh the hulk and
the mcu he's so nerfed he never gets to
be strong blah blah blah but hulk is
nerfed all the time in the comics he's
constantly like oops i fell asleep or
like oops i for whatever reason i
couldn't change
sorry i had too much rice for lunch and
i fell asleep
i mean that's essentially what happened
in infinity war a little bit so it's
like i mean yeah that's what happened
what was that
you got all those carbs in your belly
you want to take a sweet snooze
it's a good point exactly sweet
i feel like this is like even more um
plausible because of just the nature of
the grand master because we know the
grand master is an elder of the universe
and that all the elders of the universe
are obsessed with their particular hobby
so like the collector is obsessed with
collecting a bunch of people against
their will and making them slaves and uh
the grandmaster's like obsessed with
collecting a bunch of people against
their will and making them fight i love
them
you guys are just really into their
hobbies you just made
the most powerful beings in the universe
just a couple of nerds who can't get
over collecting funko pops
essentially um
the collector's collecting fungus
they're really passionate
who have families they're super
passionate about it they love their
hobbies they have such a big interest
and they love them
it's like thanos was really really
passionate about balance
it was really inspiring
free and balanced basically yeah it's
really all about what you're passionate
about really
right
seeing seeing him finally achieve a life
goal was really wholesome i really like
that thanos is a conservationist he's a
beautiful man
he's like
he would support the green new deal all
right that's that's all i'm saying the
green news
anyway
hulk is the green new deal
yeah
is the green new deal because
she is the new deal yeah
exactly put all the hulks on giant
hamster wheels have them power the world
keep them exactly keep them moving
the windows
wherever the leader is he's like i'm
making hipster wheels for both i like
that
now i want to get a little hamster and
name it she-hulk
but like do you guys think that like you
know we're going to actually see the
grand master in this series at all i do
i predicted that oh
oh
i predicted i don't know
my
he was one of my cameos
oh really dude i don't know i mean like
he was removed from uh for love and
thunder yeah um his cameo was removed so
like maybe they removed it to put him in
jail oh
okay yeah that 100 makes sense that's
really yeah
yeah yeah i agree with that yeah that
happened
all right
we're supporting your fantasy
predictions tommy i appreciate that
you're a smart man that's smart little
tommy um but all right now it is time
for overall judgment do you guys think
that this idea of she-hulk ending up on
sakaar battling and
ripping heads off in the name of the
grandmaster do you guys think that that
is rogus bogus or ogus i'll go first
because it supports my theory so i'm
going to big old rogues
self-serving
you know i'm in for number one all the
time you know i'll take it yeah
i support number one tommy as well thank
you um
what do you guys think what about you
whitney i'm gonna go for rogus baby i
want to see she-hulk in the ring
hell yeah that sounds great put her in
there with like ronda rousey let's go
let's do a little mma lady on ladies
let's go let's do it
the grand master just randomly has round
the rocks
yeah he's like he's like in this corner
she fell into a portal and she fell into
a portal
i'll say this mt you know she-hulk
she's she's incredible
she's really awakened something inside
of me you know
seeing her same that shot of her jumping
and you're you're on the ground and
she's coming down on you with her her
lovely athletic shorts and her big green
foot it changed me it changed me it
really did i wish that were me brandon i
didn't know i had that that feeling
inside of me but i i will say this empty
about your your theory
i'm gonna have to say it
is
bogus and here's why here's why i think
i laid it out i think i laid it out okay
she's staying on earth i don't think i
think okay hulk certainly goes away
i think you take him away but we need we
need our lady of justice our lady of big
green feet
we need those green feet roaming the
earth what are you talking about empty
no like that does make i do see that for
sure because like if like for some
reason if hulk just gets taken by the
grand master to go fight instacart again
it would be nice to have another hulk on
earth i hope i'm wrong i hope i'm wrong
empty i hope you're right what good
storytelling would be but
right it would be really fun if she was
on the car but like i can also see uh
jen taking up the role as the earth's
main halt for a bit if bruce does end up
getting kidnapped by the grand master um
so yeah no i i definitely will take that
bogus because
you know it's very likely that it could
happen as well so it could not happen i
don't know what i'm saying but thank you
guys two rogues isn't a bogus i'll take
it uh it's still a good day but up next
brandon has a super rogue theory about a
scroll hiding among us but first be sure
to head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can grab
our newest latest obsession merch lady
justice inspired by the she-hulk series
this limited edition shirt won't be
available for long and when you purchase
it you unlock the ability to get a
custom shout out that will appear on our
inside marvel after show hosted by me
eric voss and jessica clements so check
out our latest obsession shirt and all
of our other amazing merch options over
at new rockstarsmerch.com today and we
also want to thank upside for sponsoring
this video whether you've noticed the
high prices at the grocery store or the
increase of the cost of a dozen blades
and drummies at your favorite wing spot
one thing is clear inflation is hitting
us all where it hurts and it really
hurts a lot that's why many of us here
at new rockstars have started using
upside upside is an incredible app for
anyone who buys gas groceries or dines
out with every purchase you can earn
cash back thanks to upside to get
started download the free upside app in
the app store or google play and you use
our promo code rogue theory and get five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of ten dollars or more and next
you can claim an offer for whatever
you're buying on upside check in at the
business pay as usual with a credit or
debit card and get paid it's pretty
great in comparison to credit card
rewards or loyalty programs you can earn
three times more cash back with upside
you can cash out any time to your bank
account paypal or an e-gift card for
amazon and other brands upside users are
earning more than a million dollars
every week that's probably why they have
a 4.8 star rating on the app store many
folks here love using upside it's so
simple to use the app to find a gas
station or restaurant in your area with
an offer it makes picking a place to
dine on a friday night easy and
rewarding so download the free upside
app and use promo code rogue fury to get
five dollars or more cash back on your
first purchase of ten dollars or more
that's five dollars or more cashback on
your first purchase of ten dollars or
more using the promo code rogue theory
we also want to thank verity for
sponsoring this video podcast as well
whatever it is it's both the end of
summer is just around the corner but we
don't want summer to end now do we we
don't we want to stretch it out to into
infinity and beyond the faraday family
lives for this time of the year and
their brand captures that feeling of
summer adventure in their collection of
high quality clothing that's incredibly
soft and comfortable and always
sustainably minded and meant to be worn
from surf to city ferry is a family-run
brand making high-quality timeless
clothing with modern design and
functionality they've mastered the art
of the perfect summer outfit their
clothes are so effortless but they look
good they're super comfortable but
designed with intention which is very
important with clothes you got to have
intention you look at their clothes and
you think this must be old adventures in
ill-fitting but it's not it's got that
vintage look but it's like it was made
just for you you the person that's what
verity does best i love my precious
looks from verity i've worn a few of
their linen laguna shirts to some
outdoor events this year and i've just
been showered with compliments like all
just for putting on a shirt it's kind of
weird but hey i'll take the attention
and my mother never gave it to me their
clothes are thoughtfully crafted with a
classic style and you will wear them
over and over and over again verity is
so committed to sustainability that they
even have a lifetime guarantee of
quality and they replace or fix your
clothes forever no matter what so your
clothes can last as long as your
favorite summertime memory so right now
faraday is giving all rogue theory
listeners including you 20
off let me say it one more time in case
your ears are not doing well right now
20 percent off head to ferrity brand.com
and use the code rogue checkout to get
this deal today that's code rogue at
faraday f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brand.com rogue for 20
off
parodybrand.comrogue today all right now
it is time for our second topic for
today which will be presented by the
amazing off-screen producer brandon take
it away that's right completely amazing
and incredible it's in my resume don't
don't forget it incredible like the hulk
and just like the hulk i have some anger
issues where's my anger
it's placed at the skrulls who are
hiding among us now mt and i did a big
question not too long ago where we we
laid out some of our skrull candidates
and i've been really mulling over one
that i kind of just popped off the dome
but now i'm very suspicious okay
i think our boy the beloved winter
soldier himself bucky barnes is a skrull
and i think he's been a scroll for quite
some time okay my friends
yeah i think what i think happened
the winter scroll jerk is real whitney
get it get it right oh my god i've been
reviewing the evidence okay bucky barnes
okay new yorker
uh chain smoker uh i probably did
cocaine it was okay in the twenties and
thirties to do that it was just nice
it was more than okay it wasn't
cocaine used to be freer they used to
give it to kids on the first day of
school they'd be like here's your
long ration of cocaine jimmy
that's true
cocaine makes you big and strong it was
always bad by wednesday it's supposed to
last the whole week um
he goes in he goes into world war ii a
human okay he's a human he's a human
he's a human pow he's a human freed by
his buddy steve rogers and he's a human
helen commando he falls off the train a
human and dies because it's a 50-foot
fall at least if not more hundreds of
feet so he fell into like a chasm right
like it was like a
zola finds him and he's like i'm going
to make our own
a super soldier just you see and the red
skull is like
[ __ ] right i'm so pink
[Laughter]
zola tries to do it
it doesn't work
bucky dies but bucky completely dies
uh but but there are already scrolls on
the planet at this point they're they're
already here and and the
the hydra has found some
so
zola takes a scroll he takes the memory
he has the power to take the memories
and and the thoughts of bucky and puts
that personality into this
because he knows
he knows that steve is going to flip his
lid that's the one way to stop captain
america is to show him his dead buddy
like
absolutely
so
he mind wipes the dead bucky takes the
memories puts them into a mind-wipe
scroll
he does tommy he's got he cuts the
scroll's arm up because it's got a match
because red skull has no idea what's
going on the only one that knows about
this scroll plot is zola himself
uh and this is what goes into
uh hydra's hands and gets frozen and
unfrozen
throughout time is a skrull who thinks
he's buggy barnes he has no idea he has
no idea okay
a weekend at bucky's on campus
yes
yes they are it's weekend at bucky's
whitney that's exactly what it is
every weekend baby we're doing a lot of
branding on this episode i like this
we've got a lot of franchises these are
freebies
these are freebies for you kevin
[Music]
[Laughter]
now you might be saying well surely the
wakandans when when steve drops his his
buddy bucky off at wakandan daycare they
they surely notice that this is not a
human that this is a scroll okay and
they do they do but they don't tell
steve they're like we're going to keep
this little secret because the wakandans
they're they're they're playing nice now
they're being like we're open up to the
world we're going to share our tech but
they are still very paranoid they're
very suspicious and they don't trust
anybody and they know about the skrulls
and they're not warning anybody they
know about the
atlanteans soon to be the talocians or
whatever we're going to call them
they know about squirrels they know
about all this stuff they're not warning
earth at all
they know that bucky is actually a
skrull and so when they fixed his brain
they've implanted their own stuff into
that brain and now they have their hands
on a super scroll with a little wakandan
tech on it walking around and when the
time is right they're gonna activate it
so bucky's gonna get activated again but
this time as a scroll soldier for the
wakanda acknowledged
boxcar oh [ __ ]
ready to comply
ready
so that's incredible that's my rogues of
theories bucky actually did die and it's
been a scroll this whole time an old ass
cap is we're finally gonna see who he is
and they're gonna tell him right before
he dies
no you can't do that you actually
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
like good news cap you're going to see
real bucky real soon in hell
[Applause]
theory does does captain america go to
hell when he dies probably i hope so
probably right that's true does he go to
hell you kill a lot of people killed a
lot of people
all captains go to that son of a [ __ ]
listen that man lost his virginity in
1940. that was against wedlock he's
going straight to hell
i mean we now know that
so he's definitely going to hell you
only get into heaven straight to hell i
think this is all about mystery
i think this is all in this direction
and we're going to find out that steve
was pure as the driven snow
hmm
[Music]
i don't know about that i i actually am
going to create a new uh a new ranking
for this theory
okay i'm not going to give you a bogus
or a rogus or nogus
but this is about brotherhood
this is about oh lies
this is about
impersonations
i'm giving this
two broguses
and they [ __ ]
brogas
oh my god it's a brogus the first ever
brogan i love that i've oh my goodness
that's a it's a big betrayal it's a big
betrayal to see uh a scrub bucky let me
tell you um but i i really like i also
have to you know agree with tommy
because like this is super broke it's
super rogues um because like
this idea of of bucky being a scroll
it actually means something in the mcu
because like of um bucky's relationship
with sam and bucky's relationship with
uh steve rogers it's like you know the
squirrel invasion was a huge impact in
the comics because anybody literally
jarvis was a scroll yeah and like he put
in the scroll jarvis betrayed tony stark
and like almost made him die by picking
up his suit but like man like it could
be anybody so like if if they did
replace bucky i feel like that would be
like really impactful like the secret
invasion series because like we need to
have this distrust we need to not trust
any single person
like anybody could be a scroll and like
i i hope the mcu really um oh he's
breaking loose out there right now by
making are the scrolls coming for the
tommy
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's what happens when you don't um
check the the fuel gauges or whatever
your script thinks yeah
i brought it around i run around
oh i'm sorry that'll be that'll be a
great reference that no one in the
audience understands i know don't put
that in the video it's true that the
skrulls love catalytic converters they
need them to keep their ships running so
watch out that's why squirrels are
constantly robbing priuses in the
greater
areas that's why every skrull has a has
a little hacksaw on them at all times
just in case
and robots steal your medicine which
they use as fuel
i like it thomas thanks that's a good
that's a good 30 year old snl reference
yeah hell yeah
it would be over for you
i would love to give c-3po
a 40-milligram lexapro
and just
that much
electrical problems
i'm looking at all my prescriptions
right now and you know what i would give
bb-8 i'd give him a lycena pro for his
blood pressure because he's a little
round oh hallelujah
for sure
then this is uh tommy's a pharmacist at
tbs yeah i just take a lot of pills guys
i don't know
anything i could find so so far we have
we have two brogues well what do you
think whitney i'm giving it a brogus now
that i know that that's a rating are you
kidding i'm using drugs every day now my
man it's like level two rogues
brogues and scrogas at the same time
because it's a squirrel and a bro let's
go brogas and scrogus baby that's what
this is this thumb is brogus this thumb
is scrogus let's let's
um yes no i i think that this theory is
so good and like i would really
um i kind of want this to happen because
like even though a lot of people would
be probably really pissed because they
love a lot of bucky stands just throwing
themselves off bridges at this news
it would be devastating exactly but like
because it's bucky and like you said
because bucky is routinely getting his
memories wiped by hydra um it's very
possible that he has no idea that he
could be a squirrel because he doesn't
have that knowledge within him so like
he's just constantly in his bucky form
because that's all he knows so
he technically would be bucky like
that's true this is the ship of theseus
all over again yeah
exactly like that's 100 percent of the
shipping
what you're referring to is uh heroes
season two when they put uh
nathan's
nathan's conscience inside siler and
then made him shape-shift oh my god
because nathan was dead and that's a
good guy
damn you writer strike
you ruined heroes why did you do that
um
man that was my favorite show for such a
long time also because of hate mostly
because of hate independence here but
she was she was she used to be my older
she was your first crush
but anyway
that was my old hayley seinfeld back in
high school and girls what can we say
yeah
these girls like it
these women they grow up too much for mt
and he moves on to a younger model
oh my god sorry hayden no
80 cycles in her 20s what are you
talking about anyway um all right
um two wait was it three purposes yeah
we finished voting yes yes three
broguesses yeah yeah which makes brandon
i i don't know why i keep declaring a
winner because this show doesn't have
winners but no
our winner for today yeah
he's the rogue theory
winner
i don't know i'm doing the worm i mean
what do you call this it's not the worm
that's like the wave
yeah the wave
i don't know wait i'm gonna toss a wave
to you all the way from boston are you
ready yes three two one wave
who's that
hey waiting for it to cross the other
people
well everyone's in a different boxing
difference that was a successful wave
everybody box i forgot i forgot that we
don't have to say
i'm sorry
i was like tommy go brandon go okay i'll
go
[Laughter]
but now it is time for our roll question
are you guys ready for this one my
friend yeah
all right because now that she-hulk is
finally here thank god i've been waiting
for you jennifer walters who do you
think would be the rogues hero to be
sued in court and defended by jennifer
walters barack
hussein
obama
he is in marvel comics he is in marvel
comics yes
marvel comics canon isn't spider-man
what does he get sued for tommy breaking
hearts and ripping farts
uh
i think barack's pretty good yeah
that's a good answer
that's a pretty that's defending his
like anti i don't know barack claims on
twitter it's like oh i need jennifer
walters like uh jen uh i need you here i
can't do barack i don't know why you're
trying anyway um
what do you guys think i think that i
want jennifer walters to take a special
interest specifically
in uh male youtube apology videos she's
gonna represent all of those guys
she's gonna represent every guy that has
to start off a video
with this pose because wow she will
never be out of my job what's up guys
this video is going to be a little
different today than what you usually
see on this channel
i honestly with the introduction of miss
marvel to the universe like we've now
entered the youtuber's side of the mcu
baby that cannon of the worms is now
open so jenna walters could uh i don't
know represent ninja or something i
don't know
on bizad youtube
just anyone who needs to apologize
exactly
jennifer walters they pull like she has
to defend uh the one above all kevin
feige himself yeah he gets like
pulled into the mcu and basically like
she has to defend him like everyone who
has a grievance against how their story
was handled
go up against him especially especially
all of the black widows from the red
room can be like hey hey did you have to
write it that we uh that we all got
child trafficked and then were forced
into hysterectomies
that wasn't fun for us
can we please could you come up with a
better origin story for us thank you so
much yeah i think like kevin have to
face every hero would be very
interesting i think that jennifer
walters is gonna have to represent kevin
feige when mt sues kevin feige for just
going through his twitter and ripping
off everything
in a copyright infringement lawsuit i
like this
mt's marvel trigger theory
you're too nice to be um but no that
would be amazing and like just oh just
the idea of jen walters like like
defending kevin feige would it's just so
in line with her character because she
just breaks the fourth wall all the time
yeah so i i would love if kevin feige
made a cameo in the show like for real
like i was doing that would be so funny
yeah i would that would be awesome i
hope he does he's like why do you keep
killing vision kevin why is that a thing
that you love
why do you do this why won't you just
let wanda be happy kevin come on right
but no these are again all amazing
answers but i'm gonna have to give that
rogue point to whitney yeah for her
youtube apology video love it because
let's be real those are never going away
they're never going away and they never
get older
they're never not funny because men keep
freaking out let's be real we're uh
we're no good anyway
but that is it for this episode of rogue
fairy thank you to our amazing guests
whitney van lenningham off-screen
producer brandon our winner for today
and tommy bechtold follow them all on
all our social medias because they're
all amazing people you can support our
channel by checking all of our awesome
merch over at newrockstarsmerch.com
today do it it's a great way to support
the channel and if you've got thoughts
on some of our rogue theories you can
share them on our discord so if you're
over 18 just click the link for the new
rockstars discord server in the
description and join the conversation
today you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] you can follow new
rockstars on all social platforms and be
sure to subscribe on our channel here on
youtube we love you guys so much thank
you guys for spending time with us we'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you